Please welcome Cole Sprouse.
(audience applauding)
Hello, Drew?
I am so excited to talk to you for so--
I'm excited to talk to you too.
I can't believe I've not met you truly before.
Well, and we have like an Adam Sandler in common,
not to be like bougie Hollywood.
Oh, because we both know him we should know each other but--
Oh, what are your connections, my dear?
Exactly.
I know Sandler, you know Sandler.
But I heard you were at his premiere of "Uncut Gems".
I was, yeah, that was the first time I really reconnected,
I mean, I reconnected with him that like some little
award show but he and I reconnected "Uncut Gems"
and we spent like an hour and half at the after party
of the premiere just kinda geeking out about "Big Daddy"
and what it was to film that when I was six.
Now, granted I don't remember nearly as much as he did
but he met his wife on that movie.
And so his whole life kind of went in the very specific
direction from that film.
And it was...
I definitely recall us having a drinks that night
or rather don't recall enough but I know I was having
quite a lot of drinks in front of them that night.
And yeah, it was really nice to catch up with them,
you know his schedule.
I presented him an award around that time
and I didn't wanna write a speech 'cause I like to speak
off the cuff and from the heart which is always like
more stomach churning and intimidating but--
Yeah, that's the role of the dice
a lot of people don't make any more.
So, I'm impressed with your confidence.
Thank you.
It makes me very sick going into it
but I know that it will be genuine.
And I made him tear up, which I was very proud.
Yeah, I also like to watch grown men cry.
Yes and Adam is just not a big crier.
So if you can get to him, I was like, good.
I want you to feel something.
Yeah, making comedians cries, it's like,
there's something arcane about it.
You're absolutely right.
Not just men, but comedians.
So a male--
Comedians, it's difficult.
I completely agree.
Now, you took a break from acting because you wanted to stop
and be educated and you went to NYU.
Hmm, I did.
Yeah, after my brother did the Disney,
my brother and I did the Disney show,
we went to NYU and I took a big break.
Never really anticipated I would come back but I studied,
I completed my studies in 2015?
Yeah, 2015.
And then got swept back up into the realm of acting.
I love that you studied archeology.
I was reading up a lot on some of your travels
and excavations.
Ooh.
(audience laughs)
Yes, I traveled all over for it.
I miss it quite a bit still.
It's always been that profession in the back of my mind
that I imagine I'll eventually return to.
But it was very romantic.
I mean, taking into account I'd spent the previous
eight years of my life before college homeschooled
and in a sound stage, there's a tremendous wisdom
that comes from traveling.
I believe traveling and the privilege of traveling
to be one of the greatest educations that we can receive.
But it is a privilege and I'd studied a profession
that sort of forced me to grow and learn
and I think that acting, the currency of acting
is kind of empathy that you accrue from traveling
and learning about other people and other lives.
And it seemed honestly in a strange way,
archeology and the study of travel became the greatest
acting training that I could have gotten as well.
I couldn't agree more.
I love that you said it's a luxury
because that humility is so important
but I do think it is the best education.
The more you know about people in different places,
the more educated you are going to be
in the most profound and important ways that you cannot get
from study or in a book.
But speaking of travel, you showed up at the desk
of Conde Nast Traveler and--
Yeah.
Huh?
And you said, hi, I'm Cole Sprouse, can you give me a gig?
Yeah, pretty much.
I studied a couple of photography classes
when I was in college and I knew that I was gonna be
traveling a lot for archeology.
So I started taking my camera around with me
and Conde Nast, still I think had a publication
named Traveler magazine.
And I walked into the office with the button up shirt
and basically said, hey, I'll work for free
because I'm traveling, I might as well take some pictures
for you guys and I wanna see my stuff in print.
And they said, yes.
And I didn't get paid the first couple of times
as is the classic tale of the unpaid intern in New York.
I didn't get paid for like the first year.
But then, then I got a nice job.
You ended up hooking up with Yolanda Edwards.
Who's someone who--
Yeah, how do you know Yolanda?
(Drew laughs)
Well, I love your photography.
And I have taken photography myself but I just think
that it's one of the sides of you that I find so compelling
as well as all the others.
Go on.
And I love, I love your photography.
And so I wanted to know the origin,
by the way I subscribed to Yolo Journal.
I follow her.
Honestly, what a life those guys live?
I know and the way they show travel, it hurts.
It hurts me, yeah.
Tell us a few magazines that now
have printed your photography.
Oh man.
I think, yeah, what is that?
I think that's Guenevere.
That I was a personal shoot.
That was Jimmy Choo, Timberland collaboration.
That was Paper.
Yes, that's Sydney Sweeney from "Euphoria"
That was L Magazine.
Yeah, oh, these are fun.
That was just me taking pictures of fog bank crawling in.
Very angstical.
That was Montclair in Iceland.
I think your work is stunning and I love
that you showed up and would work for free as an intern
to start your photography journey and it has paid off
for all of us who get to see it.
By the way, we're gonna go to commercial break
really quickly, your nails.
Well.
You like them?
(audience applauding)
Yes I do.
Okay, I like them too.
And my roommate in the house paint them
'cause I can't do it, I'm not dextrous enough.
And this is straight vodka so, I don't have--
(Drew laughing)
Well, for men not crying to men wearing nail polish,
I'm so in.
(bright upbeat music)